right dr. Wolk thank you for taking my
call
yes ma'am I have a friend that six
months ago they remove her thyroid gland
and she had cancer on it and she also
refused to have red radiation she also
doesn't have her gallbladder and she's
type 2 diabetes she's going through
menopause and she complained a lot about
her neck and back pain and she wants to
know also if the pain on her neck is
because of that thigh root that they was
in her thyroid
probably not okay but she had a lot of
stuff here how much does she weigh 158
pounds and she's five - she's 46 years
old okay if I were joking
all right Charmaine now what's going on
here this friend of Theresa she has her
thyroid off because of thyroid cancer
okay she had her gallbladder removed
probably causes a pain on the right side
she has type 2 diabetes she's got
musculoskeletal stuff okay in her neck
and back
what's her underlying problem here she's
got a gluten intolerance and she's not
able to absorb nutrients what little
there is on the food okay there you go
and so what would you do for her to
support your immune system which is your
best friend when you have cancer history
cancer and what would you do for the you
know to support healthy blood sugar
healthy maintenance repair cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
we got a gallbladder missing and what
would you do for her immune system to
you know help her I would not give her
any thyroid stuff okay will be enough in
the basic program for maintenance but I
wouldn't give her any more to push the
thyroid okay because the history cancer
in it okay so what what would you do for
her diet wise and also supplement
program what I would get her I would get
around a gluten-free diet obviously and
none of the band's little oil so for an
animal fentanyl meets deli meats and
then I would get her on to healthy brain
and her
PACS okay I would get her on some gluco
gel I would get her on some sweeties and
I would get her on some ultimate enzymes
and then that's her gallbladder in a
bottle and it has a vial in it and then
some vitamin d3 okay excellent vitamin
d3 and yep that's it yep and so also
some what what would you do for
maintance repair cartilage and ligaments
in addition to the two health even brain
hard packs I said gluco gel gluco gel
yes ma'am okay get two bottles of Lube
using 15 of those a day vitamin d3
through those twice a day and what could
you do in addition to getting rid of the
fried susan the process meets in the
oils the glutens we brought around ode
when people have a thyroid problem
there's another thing you need to remove
out of the diet what what class of
nutrients would you get on Christofias
vegetables very good no cruciferous
vegetables no cabbage broccoli
cauliflower Brussels sprouts or kale
because they interfere with thyroid
function and may even you know eat a lot
of that stuff who knows and so you just
stay away from it completely and that's
going to quiet things down also
but char is exactly right it's
imperative the chi and everybody in the
household give her the fried foods the
process meteorology glutens and
cruciferous vegetables the sweeties and
her body weight at ever two bottles a
month of the sweetie so as you can take
three of those twice a day if she's on
medication which she probably is
she's a checker fasting blood sugar
every morning and as her blood sugar
drops and it will she needs to reduce
her medications her doctors taught her
to do okay and let's see here
I think that's where we want to go with
all that and I would never take one or
two of those ultimate enzymes say two
minutes before each meal couple ounces
of water and so that the enzymes are
waiting for the food down in the stomach
and also at bile ox bile that's in there
is going to help her absorb good fats
and also help her absorb the fat level
vitamins A D and K and so you need that
bile and if they take another
gallbladder who knows what's going on in
there but usually that's the cause of a
gluten problem the ascending colon the
transverse colon the descending colon
are painful we have gluten problems in
there and though the only thing doctors
do this
transfer said well you got paint under
your ribs on the right side we'll take
your gallbladder out and 99% of amount
of time that doesn't solve the problem
because the gallbladder doesn't create
gall stones and so deliver that does
that that although just an innocent bag